[Musica]
viviamo in un mondo in cui ogni parola
il suo clone visita le ci avete mai
pensato
basta aggiungere una e all'inizio di una
certa parola per trasformarla nella sua
versione 2.0 lasciatemi fare due esempi
e commerce commercio elettronico
ejustice giustizia elettronica e voting
voto elettronico e government
amministrazione digitale e democracy
democrazia digitale
qual è il vero significato di quella e
serve soltanto a svecchiare il termine
sopportarlo al passo con la tecnologia
oppure l'aggiunta di quella semplice
lettera è in grado di trasformare la
parola in qualcosa di altro da sé stessa
qualcuno di voi si starà chiedendo che
cosa c'entri questo con la democrazia
digitale
ebbene io credo che per parlare di
democrazia digitale sia necessario
capire anzitutto se questa sia ancora
una vera democrazia per poter essere
definita tale
la democrazia digitale dovrebbe
garantire attraverso l'uso delle nuove
tecnologie
la libertà di manifestazione del
pensiero
l'uguaglianza tra i cittadini la
corretta informazione di questi ultimi
prima dell'espressione di un voto di una
preferenza il confronto equilibrato tra
orientamenti contrapposti e noi siamo
davvero sicuri che le nuove tecnologie
siano in grado di garantire tutto questo
guardiamoci attorno
certamente la libertà di manifestazione
del pensiero è favorita dall uso delle
nuove tecnologie
ciascuno di noi ha un microfono che può
utilizzare per far sentire la propria
voce in rete
e tuttavia a differenza della
manifestazione del pensiero offline per
circolare on line le nostre idee hanno
bisogno di un qualche cosa di più hanno
bisogno della collaborazione degli
algoritmi si gli algoritmi quegli
intermediari severi che stabiliscono chi
possa leggere cosa per quanto tempo e
secondo quale ordine che cosa accadrebbe
se un giorno un algoritmo spegnesse quel
microfono che ciascuno di noi ha
e magari oscurando il post che abbiamo
pubblicato oppure pubblicandolo sì ma
secondo un ordine particolare che lo
pone di fatto in coda a tutti gli altri
e ne impedisce la lettura da parte di
chiunque la nostra voce così formalmente
consegnata alla rete finirebbe per non
essere sentita da nessuno per parlare
online
abbiamo quindi bisogno degli algoritmi e
ne siamo condizionati
abbiamo una libertà che sia condizionata
non è una vera libertà anche
l'uguaglianza è formalmente garantita
dalla rete e anzi ne costituisce il
fondamento stesso
eppure anche in questo caso qualcosa non
torna pensiamo al voto elettronico una
delle frontiere della democrazia
digitale e adesso immaginiamo di andare
dal nostro nonno e di dirgli che da
domani non potrà più votare come ha
sempre fatto apponendo un segno su una
scheda cartacea ma dovrà utilizzare il
tablet il seggio
oppure il computer da casa molto
probabilmente quello stesso nonno si
lancerà una serie di maledizioni e
rinuncerà a esprimere quel bordo
vedete non sempre la tecnologia è in
grado di far avvicinare i cittadini alla
politica talvolta li allontana da essa
la tecnologia non è per tutti
e tuttavia tutti abbiamo pari diritto di
prendere parte ai processi democratici
sull'informazione apparentemente non
possiamo dire nulla
chi tra di noi infatti non concorda sul
fatto che le nuove tecnologie
favoriscano la circolazione delle
informazioni
in effetti grazie all'avvento della rete
informarsi è diventato più semplice ma
allo stesso tempo più complesso è
probabile infatti che le informazioni a
cui io accesso siano diverse dalle
informazioni a cui voi avete accesso a
cui hanno accesso i vostri familiari i
vosti amici chi risiede accanto è ancora
una volta il merito se così lo possiamo
definire è degli algoritmi che ci
studiano che cercano di capire quali
sono i nostri gusti le nostre preferenze
e ci suggeriscono ciò che è esattamente
corrisponde ai nostri interessi
informazioni comprese ciascuno di noi
finisce per essere immerso all'interno
di una sorta di bolla intelligente una
bolla impermeabile che lascia passare
ciò che ci ha fine e non tiene
all'esterno lontano da noi ciò che non
lo è è anche una bolla in cui tutto
corre veloce non abbiamo il tempo di
verificare che le informazioni che
abbiamo reperito in rete siano veritiere
e corrette anche quando su quelle
informazioni baseremo le nostre
convinzioni le nostre credenze o
esprimeremo un voto queste bolle
intelligenti di finiscono per essere la
nostra finestra sul mondo una finestra
personalizzata tagliata su misura per
noi ma anche una finestra parziale
limitante che si rimanda un'immagine
talvolta distorta della realtà
in questo universo bolle individuali
anche il confronto è diventato più
difficile
gli algoritmi infatti ragionano per
affinità non super diversità e le bolle
lasciano passare soltanto quegli
orientamenti di quelle opinioni che noi
stessi condividiamo
siamo talmente abituati a confrontarci
con idee credenze simili alle nostre
che qualsiasi opinione orientamento
diverso
finisce per infastidirci abbiamo smesso
di allenare il muscolo della tolleranza
e ci siamo dimenticati di quanto sia
importante fare esperienza della
diversità
dobbiamo quindi rassegnarsi a una
democrazia digitale profondamente
diversa dalla democrazia analogica
davvero è bastato aggiungere una
semplice lettera per trasformare la
democrazia in qualcosa di altro da sé
stessa
io credo di no io credo che tra
democrazia digitale e democrazia
analogica non possa e non debba esserci
alcuna differenza è che la tecnologia in
sé sia solo uno strumento per dare forma
a ciò in cui veramente crediamo per far
sì che la democrazia digitale sia ancora
una vera democrazia
abbiamo bisogno dell'articolo 1 della
costituzione che individua nel lavoro il
fondamento della nostra repubblica
democratica
lavoro come sinonimo di impiego ancor
prima lavoro come sinonimo di impegno
l'impegno delle istituzioni certo ma
anche impegno di ciascuno di noi a
praticare ogni giorno la democrazia
in che modo rimanendo aperti al dialogo
e praticando la tolleranza non l'odio
anche in rete sforzandoci di verificare
che le informazioni che reperiamo siano
veritiere e corrette prendendo parte
attivamente ai processi democratici e
cercando nel nostro piccolo di
promuovere l'alfabetizzazione digitale
da ultimo ma non per importanza esigendo
che la rete e gli algoritmi non
dimentichino quali sono i veri valori
democratici è necessario che ciascuno di
noi scoppi questa sorta di bolla in cui
si ritrova immerso per cercare di
contribuire alla creazione di una
democrazia digitale che sia davvero
degna di questo nome
l'impegno di ciascuno di noi è
essenziale in mancanza infatti in questo
universo di bolle individuali potrebbe
non esserci più spazio per la vera
democrazia né per una democrazia
analogica né per una democrazia digitale